It is time for a Hank update.
Being so big, I don't even know how old he is right now.
I think he is four and a half months old,
I think. It's hard to keep track.
He's huge. He's still a puppy,
and he's still so sweet and fun.
We found out that he loves the water,
so he plays in the water in the backyard with the kids,
like, almost every day.
He's just like one of the kids.
We think he was allergic to some ingredient that was in his food,
so we had to swap out his food,
and he's doing a lot better now.
He's just, like,
so chill, so nice,
so sweet with the kids. Very hyper,
very playful, which is good for our family,
because that's what we're like.
And we are always on the go.
We're always doing stuff. But he's been so good.
He doesn't really chew up anything.
He's just so much fun. He's a perfect little pup.
I'm gonna set him down, though,
because I don't know how to hold him correctly
at my stage. He's the best.
He loves to fetch, he knows how to sit,
he knows how to shake and lay down,
and he knows his name,
and some of you guys gave suggestions of how to do that,
so we did a lot of different,
like, reward things with him.
Anyway, I gotta go,
but that's the update. He's doing great so far.
The vet Says he'll probably be fully grown by the time he's one.
And he's already huge, so I don't know how big he's gonna get.
Think he's gonna get big. Talk to you later.